with that mr. Holmes you are now
recognized for your opening statement
and when you conclude dr. hill you'll be
immediately recognized thereafter for
your opening statement thank you good
morning mr. chairman ranking member
Nunez and members of the committee my
name is David Holmes and I'm a career
foreign service officer at the
Department of State since August 2017
I've been a political counsellor at the
US Embassy in Kiev Ukraine while is it
is an honor to appear before you today I
want to make clear that I did not seek
this opportunity to testify today since
you determined that I may have something
of value to these proceedings and issued
a subpoena it is my obligation to appear
and to tell you what I know
indeed as Secretary Pompeo has stated I
hope everyone who testifies we'll do so
truthfully and accurately what when they
do the oversight role will have been
performed and I think America will come
to see what took place here that is my
only goal to testify truthfully and
accurately to enable you to perform that
role and to that end I put together this
statement to lay out as best I can
my recollection of events that may be
relevant to this matter by way of
background I have spent my entire
professional career as a foreign service
officer like many of the dedicated
public servants who have testified in
these proceedings my entire career has
been in the service of my country on a
graduate of perón of Pomona College in
claremont california and receive degrees
in international affairs from the
University of st. Andrews in Scotland
and from Princeton University's Woodrow
Wilson School of Public and
International Affairs I joined the
Foreign Service in 2002 during a
political merit-based process under the
George W Bush administration and I've
proudly served administration's of both
parties and worked for their appointees
both political and career prior to my
current post in Kiev Ukraine I served in
the political and economic sections at
the US Embassy in Moscow Russia in
Washington I served on the National
Security Council staff as director for
Afghanistan and as a special assistant
the Undersecretary of State
my prior overseas assignments include
New Delhi India Kabul Afghanistan Bogota
Colombia and Pristina Kosovo as the
political counselor at the US Embassy in
Kiev I lead the political section
covering Ukraine's internal politics
Foreign Relations and security policies
and I serve as the senior policy and
political ambassador to the about
advisor to the ambassador the job of an
embassy political counsellor is to
gather information about the host
country's political landscape to report
back to Washington to represent US
policies to foreign contacts and to
advise the Ambassador on policy
development and implementation in this
role I'm a senior member of the
embassies country team and continually
involved in addressing issues as they
arise
I'm also often called upon to take notes
in meetings involving ambassador or
visiting senior US officials with
Ukrainian counterparts for this reason
I've been present in many of the
meetings with president szalinski and
his administration some of which may be
germane to this inquiry while I'm a
political counselor at the Embassy it is
important to note that I'm not a
political appointee or engaged in US
politics in any way it is not my job to
cover or advise on US politics on the
contrary I'm an apolitical foreign
policy professional and my job my job is
to focus on the politics of the country
in which I serve so that we can better
understand the local landscape and
better advance US national interests
there in fact during the period that
we'll cover today my colleagues and I
followed direct guidance from ambassador
Jovanovic and ambassador Taylor to focus
on doing our jobs as foreign policy
professionals and to stay clear of
Washington politics I arrived in Kiev to
take up my assignment as political
counselor in August 2017
a year after ambassador you wanted to
receive her appointment from August 2017
until her removal from post in May 2019
I was ambassador Jovanovic his chief
policy advisor and developed a deep
respect for her dedication determination
decency and professionalism
during the
time we work together closely speaking
multiple times per day and company
ambassador Jovanovic too many of her
meetings with senior Ukrainian
counterparts our work in Ukraine focused
on three policy priorities peace and
security economic growth and reform an
anti-corruption and rule of law
these policies match the three
consistent priorities of the Ukrainian
people since 2014 as measured in public
opinion polling namely an end to the
conflict with Russia that restores
national unity and territorial integrity
responsible economic policies that
deliver European standards of growth and
opportunity an effective and impartial
rule of law institutions that deliver
justice in cases of high-level official
corruption our efforts on this third
policy priority merits special mention
because it was during ambassador
Jovanovic his tenure that we achieved
the hard-fought passage of a law
establishing an independent court to try
corruption cases these efforts
strained ambassador Jovanovic his
relationship with former president
poroshenko and some of his allies
including prosecutor general yuriy
lutsenko who resisted fully empowering
truly anti truly independent
anti-corruption institutions that would
help ensure that no Ukrainians however
powerful were above the law despite this
resistance the ambassador in the embassy
kept pushing anti-corruption and other
priorities of our policy towards Ukraine
beginning in March 2019 the situation at
the embassy and in Ukraine changed
dramatically
specifically the three priorities of
security economy and justice and our
support for Ukrainian Democratic
resistance to Russian aggression became
overshadowed by a political agenda
promoted by former New York New York
City Mayor Rudy Giuliani and a cadre of
officials operating with a direct
channel to the White House that change
began with the emergence of press
reports critical of ambassador Jovanovic
and masa Nations by then prosecutor
general lute Senko and others to
discredit her in mid-march 2019 an
embassy colleague learned from a
Ukrainian contact that mr. Lutz anko had
complained
ambassador Jovanovic had quote destroyed
him with her refusal to support him
until he followed through with his
reform commitments and ceased using his
position for personal gain in
retaliation mr. Lutz anko made a series
of unsupported allegations against
ambassador of on a [ __ ] mostly
suggesting that ambassador ivanovich
improperly used the embassy to advance
the political interests of the
Democratic Party among mr. Lutz anko's
allegations were that the embassy had
ordered the investigation of a former
Ukrainian official solely because that
former official was allegedly the main
Ukrainian contact of the Republican
Party and a president Trump personally
and that the embassy had allegedly
pressured Lutz engquist predecessor to
close a case against a different former
Ukrainian official solely because of an
alleged connection between that
officials company Purisima and former
Vice President Biden's son mr. Lutz Anka
also claimed that he had never received
four point four million dollars in u.s.
funds intended for his office and that
there was a tape of a Ukrainian official
saying that he was trying to help her
like Hillary Clinton win the 2016
election finally mr. Lutz anko publicly
Klee claimed that ambassador ivanovich
had given him a do not prosecute list
containing the names of her supposed
allies an allegation the State
Department called an outright
fabrication and that mr. Lutz anko later
attracted mr. Lutz Anka said that as a
result of these allegations ambassador
Jovanovic would face serious problems in
the United States public opinion polls
indicated Ukrainians generally did not
believe mr. Lutz anko's allegations and
in Martin light on March 22nd President
poroshenko issued a statement in support
of ambassador Jovanovic following mr.
Lutz thankless allegations mr. Giuliani
and others made a number of public
statements critical of ambassador
yovanovich questioning her integrity and
calling her for her removal from office
mr. Giuliani was also making frequent
public statements pushing for Ukraine to
investigate interference in the 2016
election and issues related to buries
m'a and the Biden's for example on May
1st 2019 the New York Times reported
that mr. Giuliani had
discuss the bereavement investigation
and its intersection with the Biden's
with the ousted ukrainian prosecutor
general and the current prosecutor on
may night the new york times reported
that mr. Giuliani said he planned to
travel to Ukraine to pursue
investigations into the 2016 election
interference and into the involvement of
former Vice President Biden's son in a
Ukrainian gas company over the next few
months mr. Giuliani also issued a series
of tweets asking quote why Biden
shouldn't be investigated attacking
quote the new president of Ukraine
szalinski for being silent on the 2016
election and Biden investigations and
complaining about the New York Times
attacking him for quote exposing the
Biden family history of making millions
from Ukrainian criminals around this
time the Ukrainian presidential election
was approaching and political newcomer
and Entertainer of Olodumare szalinski
who had played a president on television
was surging in the polls ahead of mr.
Lutz anko's political ally president
poroshenko on April 20th I was president
I was present for ambassador Jovanovic
his third and final meeting with ven
candidate zolensky ahead of his
landslide victory in the runoff election
the next day as in her two prior
meetings that I also attended they had
an entirely cordial pleasant
conversation and signaled their mutual
desire to work together however the
negative narratives about ambassador
yovanovich had gained currency in
certain segments of the United States
Press on April 26th Ambassador Jovanovic
departed for Washington DC where she
learned that she would be recalled early
the barrage of allegations directed at
Ambassador yovanovich
a career ambassador is unlike anything I
have seen in my professional career
following president-elect solinsky's
victory our attention in the embassy
focused on getting to know the incoming
zalenski administration and on
preparations for the inauguration
scheduled for May 20th the same day that
ambassador Jovanovic departed post
permanently it was cool it quickly
became clear that the White House was
not prepared to show the level of
support for the zolensky administration
that we had originally anticipated
in early May mr. Giuliani publicly
alleged that mr. szalinski would
quote surrounded by enemies of the US
president and canceled a visit to
Ukraine shortly thereafter we learned
that vice president Pence no longer
planned to lead the presidential
delegation to inauguration the White
House then whittled down an initial
proposed list for the official
presidential delegation to the
inauguration from over a dozen
individuals to just five secretary Perry
as its head Special Representative for
Ukraine negotiations kurt volker
representing the State Department
national security council director Alex
Vin de Minh representing the White House
temporary acting chargee d'affaires
Joseph Pennington representing the
embassy and ambassador to the European
Union Gordon Sunland well ambassador
Stalin's mandate as ambassador
ambassador to the European Union did not
cover individual member states let alone
non-member countries like Ukraine he
made clear that he had direct and
frequent access to President Trump and
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney and
portrayed himself as the conduit to the
President and mr. Mulvaney for this
group secretary Perry ambassador Sandlin
and Ambassador Volcker later styled
themselves the three amigos and made
clear they would take the lead on
coordinating our policy and engagement
with his elinsky administration around
the same time I became aware that mr.
Giuliani a private lawyer was taking a
direct role in Ukrainian diplomacy on
April 25th Yvan Bakken oov who was mr.
solinsky's childhood friend and campaign
chair and was ultimately appointed as
the head of the security services of
Ukraine indicated to me privately that
he had been contacted by quote someone
named Giuliani who said he was an
advisor to the vice president I reported
mr. Buchanan's message to Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State George Kent
over the following months it became
apparent that mr. Giuliani was having a
direct influence on the foreign policy
agenda that the three amigos were
executing on the ground in Ukraine in
fact at one point during a preliminary
meeting of the inaugural delegation
someone wondered aloud why mr. Giuliani
was so active in the media with respect
to Ukraine my recollection is that
ambassador Sandlin stated quote damn it
Rudy every time Rudy gets involved he
goes and eff
everything up the inauguration took
place on May 20th and I took notes in
the delegations meeting with president
zalenski during the meeting secretary
Perry past president zalenski a list
that Perry described as quote people he
trusts secretary Perry told president
szalinski that he could seek advice from
the people on this list on issues of
energy sector reform which was the topic
of subsequent meetings between secretary
Perry and key Ukrainian energy sector
contacts embassy personnel were excluded
from some of these later meetings by
secretary Perry staff on May 23rd
ambassador Volcker Master Sandlin
secretary Perry and Senator Ron Johnson
who had also attended the inauguration
though not on the official delegation
returned to the United States and
briefed President Trump on May 29th
president Trump signed to congratulate
congratulatory letter to president
zalenski which included an invitation to
visit the White House at an unspecified
date it is important to understand that
a White House visit was critical to
president szalinski president Solinsky
needed to show us support at the highest
levels in order to demonstrate to
Russian President Putin that he had u.s.
backing as well as to advance his
ambitious anti-corruption reform agenda
at home President solinsky's team
immediately began pressing to set a date
for that visit president szalinski and
senior members of his team made clear
that they wanted president zelinsky's
first overseas trip to be to Washington
to send a strong signal of American
support and requested a call with
President Trump as soon as possible
we at the Embassy also believed that a
meeting was critical to the success of
President zelinsky's administration and
its reform agenda and we worked hard to
get it arranged when President
solinsky's team did not receive a
confirmed date for a White House visit
they made alternative plans for
president zelinsky's first overseas trip
to be to Brussels instead in part to
attend American Independence Day event
at Vassar somnolent hosted on June 4th
Ambassador Soglin hosted a dinner in
president's olinsky's honor following
the reception which included president
Solinsky Jared Kushner
secretary Pompeo is counselor ulrich
Breck Buhl senior european union
officials and comedian jay leno among
others ambassador Bill Taylor
arrived in Kiev as chargee d'affaires on
June 17th for the next month the focus
of our activities along with those of
the three amigos was to coordinate a
White House visit to that end we were
working with Ukrainians to deliver
things that we thought President Trump
might care about such as commercial
deals would benefit the United States
which might convince President Trump to
agree to a meeting with President
szalinski the Ukrainian policy community
was unanimous and its recommendation in
recognizing the importance of securing
the meeting and president Trump's
support ambassador Taylor reported that
Secretary of Pompeo had told him prior
to his arrival in keeve quote we need to
work on turning the president around on
Ukraine ambassador Volcker told us the
first that the next five years could
hang on what could be accomplished in
the next three months I took that to
mean that if we did not earn president
Trump's support in the next three months
we could lose the opportunity to make
progress during President solinsky's
five-year term within a week or two it
became apparent that the energy sector
reforms the commercial deals and the
anti-corruption efforts on which we were
making progress were not making a dent
in terms of persuading the White House
to schedule a meeting between the
Presidents on June 27th Ambassador
Sandlin told ambassador Taylor and a
phone conversation the gist of which
ambassador Taylor shared with me at the
time the president Solinsky needed to
make clear to President Trump that
President zalenski was not standing the
way of quote investigations
I understood that that this meant the
Biden Purisima investigations that mr.
Giuliani and his associates have been
speaking about in the media since March
while ambassador Taylor did not brief me
on every detail of his communications
with the three amigos he did tell me
that on a June 28th call with President
szalinski ambassador Taylor and a three
amigos it was made clear that some
action on Maurice ma Biden investigation
was a precondition for an oval office
visit also On June 28th while pres
Trump was still not moving forward on a
meeting with President szalinski we met
with he met with Russian President Putin
at the g20 summit in Osaka Japan
sending a further signal of lack of
support to Ukraine we became concerned
that even if a meeting between
presidents Trump and szalinski could
occur it would not go well
and I discussed with embassy colleagues
whether we should stop seeking a meeting
all together while the White House visit
was critical to this alinsky
administration a visit that failed to
send a clear and strong signal of
support likely would be worse for
president zalenski the no visit at all
Congress has appropriated 1.5 billion
dollars in security assistance for
Ukraine since 2014 this assistance has
provided crucial material and moral
support to Ukraine in its defensive war
with Russia and has helped Ukraine build
its armed forces virtually from scratch
into arguably the most capable and
battle-hardened land force in Europe
I've had the honor of visiting the main
training facility in western Ukraine
with members of Congress and members of
this very committee mr. phonic where we
witnessed firsthand US National Guard
troops along with allies conducting
training for Ukrainian soldiers since
2014 National Guard units from
California Oklahoma New York Tennessee
and Wisconsin have trained
shoulder-to-shoulder with Ukrainian
counterparts given the history of u.s.
security assistance to Ukraine and the
bipartisan record by partisan
recognition of its importance I was
shocked when on July 18th and office of
management and budget staff members
surprisingly announced the hold on
Ukrainian security assistance the
announcement came toward the end of a
nearly two hour national security
council secure video conference call
which I participated in from the embassy
conference room the official said that
the order had come from the president
had been conveyed to OMB by mr. Mulvaney
with no further explanation this began a
week or so of efforts by various
agencies to identify the rationale for
the freeze to conduct a review of the
assistance
and to reaffirm the unanimous view of
Ukraine policy community of it's
important
NSC counterparts confirmed to us that
there had been no change in our Ukraine
policy but could not determine the cause
of the hold or how to lift it on July
25th president Trump made a
congratulatory phone call to president
zalenski after his party won a
commanding majority in Ukraine's
parliamentary election contrary to
standard procedure the embassy received
no readout of that call and I was
unaware of what was discussed until the
transcript was released on September
25th upon reading the transcript I was
deeply disappointed to see that the
president raised none of what I
understood to be our interagency
agreed-upon foreign policy priorities in
Ukraine and instead raised the Biden
burry smih investigation and referred to
the theory about CrowdStrike
and its supposed connection to Ukraine
in the 2016 election the next day July
26 2019 I attended meetings the
presidential administration building and
keeve with Ambassador Kate Taylor
ambassador Volcker ambassador Sandlin
and I took notes during those meetings
our first meeting was with presidents
olinsky's chief of staff it was brief as
he'd already been summoned by presidents
olanski to prepare for a subsequent
broader meeting but he did say the
president Trump had expressed interest
during the previous day's phone call and
president zelinsky's personnel decisions
related to the Prosecutor General's
Office the delegation then met with
President zalenski and several other
senior officials during the meeting
president Solinsky stated that during
the July 25th call President Trump had
quote three times raised some very
sensitive issues and then he would have
to follow up he's Olinsky would have to
follow up on those issues when he and
President Trump met in person not having
received a readout of the July 25th call
I did not know at the time what those
sensitive issues were after the meeting
with President zalenski
ambassador Volcker and ambassador Taylor
quickly left the presidential
administration building for a trip to
the front lines
ambassador Sandlin who was to fly out
that afternoon stayed behind to have a
meeting with Andre Yair Mach a top aide
to president Solinsky
as I was leaving the meeting with
President zalenski I was told to join
the meeting with ambassador Sandlin and
mr. Guerra Mach to take notes I had not
expected to join that meeting and was a
flight of stairs behind ambassador
Soglin as he headed to meet with mr.
Yarmuth when I reached mr. Yi remarks
office ambassador Sandlin had already
gone into the meeting I explained to mr.
Guerra mocks assistant that I was
supposed to join the meeting as the
Embassy's representative and strongly
urged her to let me in but she told me
that ambassador Sandlin and mr. Guerra
Mac had insisted that the meeting be
one-on-one with no note-taker I then
waited in the anteroom until the meeting
ended along with a member of ambassador
Soglin staff and a member of the u.s.
embassy Keefe staff when the meeting
ended the two staffers and I accompanied
ambassador Soglin out of the
presidential administration building
ambassador solemn that said that he
wanted to go to lunch and I told him
basser Soglin that I'd be happy to join
him and the two staffers for lunch if he
wanted to brief me out on his meeting
with mr. Guerra Mac or discuss other
issues an ambassador song once said that
I should join the four of us went to a
nearby restaurant and sat on an outdoor
terrace i sat directly across from a
master sauna and the two staffers sat
off to our sides at first the lunch was
largely social ambassador Soglin
selected a bottle of wine that he shared
among the four of us and we discussed
topics such as marketing strategies for
his hotel business during the lunch
Ambassador Sandlin said that he was
going to call president Trump to give
him an update master silent placed a
call on his mobile phone
I heard him announce himself several
times along the lines of Gordon's song
and holding for the president it
appeared that he was being transferred
through several layers of switchboards
and assistance and I then noticed
ambassador soglin's demeanor changed and
understood that he had been connected to
President Trump well ambassador Cylons
phone was not on speakerphone I could
hear the president's voice through the
earpiece of the phone
the president's voice was loud and
recognizable an ambassador Soglin held
the phone away from his ear for a period
of time presumably because of the loud
volume
I heard ambassador song and greet the
president and explained he was calling
from keeve I heard president Trump then
clarified that ambassador Soglin was in
Ukraine
ambassador Stalin replied yes he was
Ukraine and went on to state the
president Solinsky quote loves her ass I
then heard president Trump ask so he's
going to do the investigation ambassador
song one replied that he's going to do
it adding that president Solinsky will
do anything you ask him to do even
though I did not take notes of these
statements I have a clear recollection
that these statements were made I
believe that my colleagues who were
sitting at the table also knew that
ambassador song LAN was speaking with
the president the conversation then
shifted to ambassador Stalin's efforts
on behalf of the President to assist a
rapper who was jailed in Sweden and I
can only hear ambassador song one side
of the conversation
ambassador Solomon told the president
that the rapper was quote kind of effed
there and should have pled guilty he
recommended that the president quote
wait until after the sentencing or will
only make it worse and he added that the
president should let him get sentenced
to play the racism card give him a
ticker tape when he comes home
ambassador Soglin further told the
president that Sweden quote should have
released him on your word but that you
can tell the Kardashians you tried after
the call ended ambassador Soglin
remarked that the president was in a bad
mood as ambassador Soglin stated it was
often the case early in the morning I
then took the opportunity to ask
ambassador Soglin for his candid
impression of the president's views on
Ukraine in particular I asked ambassador
Soglin if it was true that the president
did not give a expletive about Ukraine
ambassador strongly agreed that the
President did not give an expletive
about Ukraine I asked why not an
ambassador sonless stated that the
president only cares about big stuff I
noted there was big stuff going on in
Ukraine like a war with Russia
an ambassador Soglin replied that he
meant big stuff that benefits the
president like the Biden investigation
that mr. Giuliani was pushing the
conversation then moved on to other
topics upon returning to the embassy I
immediately briefed my direct supervisor
the deputy chief of mission about
ambassador soglin's call with President
Trump and my subsequent conversation
with ambassador Saud look I told others
at the Embassy about the calls
I also emailed an embassy official in
Sweden regarding the issue with us
rapper that was discussed on the call
July 26 was my last day in the office
ahead of a long planned vacation that
ended on August 6th after returning to
the embassy I told him bastard Taylor
about the July 26th call
I also repeated repeatedly referred to
the call and the conversation with
ambassador Sandlin in meetings and
conversations where the issue of the
president's interest in Ukraine was
potentially relevant at that time
ambassador Soglin statement to the
president statement of the president's
lack of interest in Ukraine was a
particular focus we understood that in
order to secure a meeting between
President Trump and president zolensky
it would have to work hard to find a way
to explain Ukraine's importance to
president Trump in terms that he found
compelling over the ensuing weeks we
continue to try to identify ways to
frame the importance of Ukraine in ways
that would appeal to the president to
determine how to lift the hold on
security assistance and to move forward
on the scheduling of a White House visit
by president zalenski Ukrainian
Ukrainian independence day August 24th
presented another good opportunity to
show support for Ukraine secretary
pompei like considered attending as
National Security Advisor Bolden had
attended in 2018 and defense secretary
mattis had attended in 2017 but in the
end nobody senior to ambassador Volcker
attend shortly thereafter on August 27th
ambassador Volk and Basra Bolton visited
Ukraine and brought welcome news that
President Trump had agreed to meet
president zalenski on September 1st in
Warsaw ambassador Bolton further
indicated that the hold on security
assistance would not be lifted prior to
the Warsaw meeting where it would hang
on whether president zalenski was able
to quote favorably impressed President
Trump I took notes and ambassador
Bolton's meetings that day with
President szalinski and his chief of
staff Bastyr Bolton told zelinsky's
chief of staff that the meeting between
the presidents and Warsaw would be quote
crucial to cementing their relationship
however President Trump ultimately
pulled out of the Warsaw trip so the
hold remained in place with no clear
means to get it lifted between the
meetings on August 27th I heard
ambassador Bolton
Express to ambassador Taylor a national
security council senior director Tim
Morrison his frustration about mr.
Giuliani's influence with the president
making clear there was nothing you could
do about it
he recommended that mr. Lutz anko his
replacement its prosecutor general
opened a channel with his counterpart
attorney general bar in place of the
informal channel between mr. Yarmuth and
mr. Giuliani ambassador Bolton also
expressed frustration about ambassador
sunland's expansive interpretation of
his mandate after President Trump
cancelled his visit to Warsaw we
continued to try to appeal to the to the
president in foreign policy and national
security terms to that end ambassador
Taylor told me that ambassador Bolton
recommended that he ambassador Taylor
send a first person cable to Secretary
of Pompeo articulating the importance of
the security assistance an ambassador
Taylor's direction I drafted and
transmitted the cable on on ambassador
Taylor's behalf on August 29th which
further attempted to explain the
importance of Ukraine and the security
assistance to u.s. national security by
this point however my clear impression
was that the security assistance hold
was likely intended by the president
either as an expression of
dissatisfaction with Ukrainians who had
not yet agreed to the Purisima bite
investigation or as an effort to
increase the pressure on them to do so
on September 5th I took notes at Senator
Johnson and Senator Chris Murphy
meetings with presidents Olinsky and
Keefe where President zalenski asked
about the security assistance although
both senators stressed strong bipartisan
congressional support for Ukraine
senator Johnson cautioned president
Solinsky that President Trump has a
negative view of Ukraine and that
president zelanski would have a
difficult time overcoming it senator
Johnson further explained that he had
been quote shocked by president Trump's
negative reaction during an oval office
meeting on May 23rd when he and the
three amigos proposed the president
Trump meet President zalenski and show
support for Ukraine on September 8th
ambassador Taylor told me quote now
they're insisting szalinski commits to
the investigation in an interview with
CNN which I took to refer to this three
amigos I was shocked the requirement was
so
civic and concrete while we advised our
Ukrainian counterparts to voice a
commitment to following the rule of law
and generally investigating credible
corruption allegations this was a demand
that president zelanski personally
commit on a cable news channel to a
specific investigation a president
Trump's political rival on September
11th the hold was finally lifted after
significant press coverage and
bipartisan congressional expressions of
concern about the withholding of
security assistance although we knew the
hold was lifted we were still concerned
that president Solinsky had committed in
exchange for the lifting to give the
request at CNN an interview we had
several indications that the interview
would occur first the S conference in
Kiev was held from September 12 to 14
and CNN's Fareed Zakaria was one of the
moderators seconds on September 13th an
embassy colleague received a phone call
another colleague who worked for
ambassador Scotland my colleague texted
me regarding that call that quote saw
Alan and his elinsky interview songless
said the Zielinski interview is supposed
to be today or Monday and they plan to
announce that a certain investigation
that was on hold will progress silence'
did not know if this was decided or if
Salman was advocate advocating for it
apparently he's been discussing this
with year buck finally also on September
13th ambassador Taylor and I ran into
mr. year mock on our way out of a
meeting with President szalinski in his
private office ambassador Taylor again
stressed the importance of staying out
of US politics and said he hoped no
interview was planned
mr. Yerma did not answer but shrugged
and resignation as if to indicate that
he had no choice in short everybody
thought there was going to be an
interview and that the Ukrainians
believed they had to do it the interview
ultimately did not occur on September
21st ambassador Taylor and I
collaborated on input he sent to Mr
Morrison to brief President Trump ahead
of a September 25th meeting that had
been scheduled with President Zielinski
in New York on the margins of the UN
General Assembly the transcript of the
July 25th call was released the same day
as of today I still I have still not
seen her yet of the September 25th
meeting as the impeachment inquiry has
progressed I followed press reports and
reviewed the statements of ambassador's
tailor and in yovanovich based on my
experiences in Ukraine my recollection
is generally consistent with their
testimony and I believe that the
relevant facts were therefore being laid
out for the American people however in
the last couple weeks I read press
reports expressing for the first time
that certain senior officials may have
been acting without the president's
knowledge or freelancing and their
dealings with Ukraine at the same time I
also read reports noting the lack of
first-hand evidence in the investigation
and suggesting that the only evidence
being a listed at the hearings was
hearsay I came to realize that I had
first-hand knowledge regarding certain
events on July 26 that had not otherwise
been reported and that those events
potentially bore on the question of
whether the President did in fact have
knowledge that those senior officials
were using the levers of diplomatic
power to influence the new Ukrainian
president to announce the opening of a
criminal investigation against president
Trump's political opponent it is at that
point that I made the observation to
ambassador Taylor that the incident I
witnessed on July 26th had acquired
greater significance which is what he
reported in his testimony last week and
is what led to the subpoena for me to
appear here today in conclusion I'd like
to take a moment to turn back to Ukraine
today this very day marks exactly six
years since throngs of pro-western
Ukrainians spontaneously gathered on
Keys Independence Square to launch what
became known as the revolution of
dignity while the protests began in
opposition to a turn towards Russia and
away from the West they expanded over
three months to reject the entire
corrupt repressive system that had been
sustained by Russian influence in the
country those events were followed by
Russia's occupation of Ukraine's Crimean
Peninsula an invasion of Ukraine's
eastern done bass region and an ensuing
war that to date has caused almost 40
thousand lives despite the Russian
aggression over the past five years
Ukrainians have rebuilt a shattered
economy adhered to a peace process and
moved economically and socially closer
to the west toward our way of life
earlier this year large majorities of
Ukrainians again chose a fresh start by
voting for a political newcomer as
president replacing 80% of their
Parliament endorsing a platform
consistent with our democratic values
our reform priorities and our strategic
interests
this year's revolution at the ballot box
underscores the despite its
imperfections Ukraine is a genuine and
vibrant democracy and an example to
other post-soviet countries and beyond
from Moscow to Hong Kong how we respond
to this historic opportunity will set
the trajectory of our relationship with
Ukraine and will define our willingness
to defend our bedrock international
principles and our leadership role in
the world Ukrainians want to hear a
clear and unambiguous reaffirmation that
our long-standing bipartisan policy of
strong support for Ukraine remains
unchanged and that we fully back it at
the highest levels now is not the time
to retreat from our relationship with
Ukraine but rather to double down on it
as we sit here as we sit here today
Ukrainians are fighting a hot war on
Ukrainian territory against Russian
aggression this week alone since I have
been here in Washington two Ukrainian
soldiers were killed and two injured by
Russian LED forces in eastern Ukraine
despite a declared ceasefire
I learned overnight that seven more were
injured yesterday as vice president
pence said after his meeting with
President Solinsky in Warsaw the u.s.
stroke rate Ukraine relationship has
never been stronger Ukrainians and their
new government earnestly want to believe
that Ukrainians cherish their bipartisan
American support that sustained their
euro-atlantic aspirations and they
recoil
at the thought of playing a role in US
domestic politics or elections at a time
of shifting allegiances and rising
competitors in the world we have no
better friends than Ukraine a scrappy
unbowed determined and above all
dignified people who are standing up
against Russian authoritarianism and
aggression they deserve better we're now
at Anna flection point in Ukraine and it
is critical to our national security
that we stand in strong support of our
Ukrainian partners Ukrainians and
freedom-loving people everywhere are
watching the example we set here of
democracy and the rule of law thank you
Thank You mr. homeless said dr. hill